For this problem, we're going to look at the relationships between
different kinds of graphs. We want to know if x
is the subset of y or y is the subset
of x or both or neither. We'd select this first
option. If every star graph is also a tree graph,
we pick this option. If every tree graph is also
a star graph, select this option, if both of these
are true; if every star graph is a tree graph and
every tree graph is a star graph. Or we'd pick this option, if neither is true.
For example, the first one is true. Every
star graph is a tree graph. In order to
get from any node, exist this simple path
through the center. To our target node. If we
start from the center, it's trivially easy to
get to any node. The reverse is not true.
This is an example of a tree graph that is not a star
graph. Here are the rest of the graph types for you to figure out.